Hallo, guten Tag. Ich heiße Josef Czellik. Ich möchte mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwere sprechen, aber zunächst brauche ich ein paar Ihre allgemeine Informationen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Rudolf Pol.
Rudolf Pol.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, Rudolf, eigentlich ganz einfach.
Ja.
Und der Familie Name Pol, P-O-H-L.
Herr Kol, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57.
Ja, 57.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. Mai, 68.
68.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,82.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege so 89 Kilo.
Ich wiege mich jetzt nicht so oft, aber du ziemlich genau stimmt das wohl.
Okay.
Welche Beschwerte haben Sie?
Ja, mir geht es seit ein paar Tagen schlecht.
Ich habe seit Tagen eigentlich schon heftigen Husten.
Und jetzt habe ich mit einmal gemerkt, dass es mir wirklich schlecht geht.
Ich habe mal Fieber gemessen, das war bei 39.
Und ich habe so einen Stirnthermometer, so ein elektronisches.
Und ich kriege eigentlich auch schlecht Luft.
Und heute Nacht habe ich geschwitzt.
Und mit hat alles weh, der ganze Brustkorb tut mir weh.
Und ich fühle mich wirklich schlecht.
Es ist irgendwie schlimmer, als jeder Husten, den ich bisher hatte.
Sie haben gesagt, ein paar Tage haben Sie Beschwerte?
Ja, der Husten ist seit fünf Tagen und er wird halt immer schlimmer.
Und jetzt, dass es mir so schlecht geht, das ist erst seit gestern Abend.
Und dann bin ich halt gleich heute morgens zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Temperatur gemessen?
Gestern Abend.
Am Stirn?
Beider Stirn, ja.
Sie haben auch Atemnot?
Ja, ich kriege nicht gut Luft.
Ich kann nicht so richtig durchatmen.
Ja, und es tut mir alles weh beim Atmen.
Bei Bewegung oder immer haben Sie Atemnot?
Eigentlich jetzt, also beim Husten ganz schlimm.
Und ja, eigentlich auch so, wenn ich mich minimal anstrenge, ja.
Wenn ich nur sitze, geht es.
Haben Sie Ausstrund nach dem Husten?
Ja, da kommt so ein ekliges, grünliches Zeug raus, ganz fies.
Grünlich?
Weißig oder?
Bitte?
Ja, weißig oder nur grünlich?
Grünlich und schleimig, ja.
Haben Sie Blut im Ausstrund bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, ich glaube nicht.
Also geblutet hat nur einmal die Nase.
Heute Morgen, ganz früh, habe ich das mit einmal gemerkt,
weil ich auch so eine leichte Schnupfnase habe, aber eigentlich nicht so typisch.
Und dann hatte ich heute Morgen beim Schnurzen einmal Nasenbluten.
Sie haben gesagt, wo ist die Schmessen?
Ja.
Die Schmessen war immer oder?
Also die sind bei Husten ganz tüchtig, dann tut das ganz doll weh.
Und auch wenn ich versuche, tief einzuabenden, das mache ich schon gar nicht mehr.
Könnten Sie die Schmessen beschreiben eher Druck oder brennend?
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, einmal habe ich so ein bisschen Druckgefühl,
aber ich habe vor allem eher einen brennenden Schmerz, würde ich sagen.
Wie stark ist die Schmerzintensität auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark ist?
Also dafür, das ist ja normalerweise beim Atmen.
Gar nicht wehtun, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, das ist halt so bei 6 oder 7.
6 bis 10, okay.
Haben Sie Herzgrofen, Herzfasen oder Herzstolpe?
Nee, also das Herz glaube ich nicht, das ist eher so, dass ich so Husten habe.
Fieber?
Haben Sie Halsschmerzen auch?
Halsschmerzen nicht, nein, Kopfschmerzen habe ich, also ja so diesen dröhn Kopf,
wenn man Fieber hat, so dieses typische, dass ich mich so fieberig und mit Kopfschmerzen habe,
ja und total schlafen.
Müdigkeit auch?
Bitte?
Haben Sie Müdigkeit?
Ja, ich habe in der Nacht natürlich fast nicht geschlafen,
oder das Gefühl, ich hätte fast nicht geschlafen, ja.
Ich bin schon müde, ja.
Vorher schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise kann ich eigentlich ganz gut schlafen, ja.
Aber gestern haben Sie nicht gut geschlafen?
Ja, gestern und vorgestern eigentlich auch schon nicht so besonders gut.
Und letzte Nacht habe ich auch gemerkt, dass ich wie verrückt geschwitzt habe, ne?
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise habe ich da eigentlich keine Schwierigkeiten,
manchmal habe ich ein bisschen Blähungen, aber ansonsten würde ich mal sagen,
habe ich da keine Schwierigkeiten.
Okay, Wasserlassen ist Frau Gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Im Augenblick mag ich ans Essen nicht denken, aber normalerweise schmeckt es mir schon gut,
ja, wenn meine Frau kocht, ja, dann esse ich schon gerne, ja.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Sagte ich ja gerade, also letzte Nacht habe ich so geschwitzt, ja.
Ja, letzte Nacht.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht verloren?
Ich bin nicht aufgefallen, also ich würde sagen, nicht.
Normalerweise, okay.
Haben Sie auch Bauchschmerzen oder?
Bauchschmerzen nicht, nein, nein.
Das tut nur hier so oben, so in der Brust beim Atmenwesen.
Das ist mir da ein, so bei jedem Atemzug, dass das schmerzhaft ist, ne?
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Nein, das reicht mir völlig, also ich fühle mich so schlecht, ja.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie vor der Krankung, ja?
Ja, also ich habe halt ein Steeberuf und dann habe ich oft Rhythmenschmerzen,
das habe ich aber schon jahrelang und ja, dann nehme ich halt manchmal,
wenn ich argische Schmerzen habe, nehme ich halt eine Tablette,
eine Schmerz-Tablette.
Und ja, was mich auch so ein bisschen quält,
das hat man vor fünf Jahren nach festgestellt, dass ich,
dass ich ein Gicht habe, ja, dass ich also ein bisschen aufpassen muss
beim Essen auch.
Und vor fünf Wochen hatte ich gerade mal so eine üble Attacke,
da hatte ich mir in dem einen großen Zee,
ganz furchtbar wiegetan, ich konnte fast nicht auftreten,
dann aber zum Glück nach ein paar Tagen wieder vorbei.
Wer meint, Sie da je ein Medikament ein?
Nein, eigentlich nehme ich kein Medikament,
ich passe nur ein bisschen auf, dass ich nicht so viel Fleisch esse
und ja, aber ansonsten mache ich da nichts.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorherklankungen?
Ja, so eine, ja, so eine Winzigkeit, ich muss halt ein bisschen aufpassen
mit Sonnenbestrahlung.
Ich habe hier an den Schlefen, da habe ich so eine Sonnenempfindlichkeit,
da muss ich immer, wenn ich da Sonne drauf bekomme,
deswegen trage ich meistens irgendwie eine Kappe
oder einen breitkrempigen Hut.
Ein Exem, oder?
Ja, dann habe ich irgendwie so eine Sonnenbier,
Allergie oder Hautveränderung halt.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament?
Nein, ich mache da nur so ein Gehl drauf.
Haben Sie, gibt es noch andere Vorherklanken?
Ja, eigentlich, sonst ist alles okay.
Jetzt habe ich mich gerade kürzlich bei der Arbeit am linken Daumen
ein bisschen verletzt, da habe ich so eine Schnittverletzung,
die muss jetzt noch wieder zuheilen, aber sonst,
ja.
Wann war das, ich rieche mal.
Das ist jetzt ein paar Tage her, dass ich mich geschnitten habe.
Ein paar Tage?
Ja.
Wurde es sich schon einmal operiert?
Ja, das war so ein kleiner Eingriff, eigentlich nur,
ich hatte so ein Kapaltunnel-Syndrom
und das ist operiert worden.
Wann war das?
Oh, das ist schon lange her, das ist vor 13 Jahren gewesen.
Vor 13 Jahren, okay.
Gibt es noch andere Operationen?
Nein, sonst ist noch nie etwas gemacht worden.
Entschuldigung, welche Seite hatte Sie Kapaltunnel-Syndrom?
Auf der linken Seite.
Auf der linken Seite, okay.
Okay.
Haben Sie allergiert?
Ja, also, irgendein,
ich habe einen Pinzellin, darf ich nicht nehmen,
das ist Amoxicillin, da habe ich mal einen heftigen Ausflach bekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergien?
Nein, nicht das.
Ich wüsste, also das ist das Einzige.
Okay.
Oder unverträglichkeiten,
vertragen Sie alle Nervesmittel, zum Beispiel Zucker
oder Milch oder Soja?
Also eigentlich kann ich alles essen, ja.
Ja, okay.
Brauchen Sie?
Ja, aber nicht viel, also ich rauche nur so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag,
wirklich nicht viel.
Können wir Senzigatensagen?
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Seit wann brauchen Sie?
Seit ich erwachse mehr, so 35, 38 Jahre.
35, 38 Jahre.
Seit 35 Jahren.
So ungefähr, ja.
Okay.
Kennen Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Alkohol, also ich trinke abends ziemlich regelmäßigen Bier,
aber...
Ein Bier, oder?
Bitte?
Ein Bier.
Ja, das ist regelmäßig, ja, klar, wenn es mal irgendwas zu feiern gibt,
oder ein gutes Essen, wenn man mal eingeladen ist,
dann trinkt man auch mal etwas anderes oder auch mal ein Glas mehr.
Okay.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen, nee, Drogen habe ich noch nie probiert.
Hab ich auch nicht vor.
Okay.
Sind in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche Vorherkrankungen bekannt,
bei Vater zum Beispiel oder Mutter?
Ja, also mein Vater, da hatte eine Staublunge, da ist er,
also noch nicht alt gewesen, als er verstorben ist.
Er hat halt in der Fabrik gearbeitet und hat da viel, viel abbekommen.
Und also, der ist mit 68 verstorben, der ist also wirklich nicht alt geworden.
Ich habe meine Mutter, ich war die bisher auch immer gesund,
aber die hatte jetzt Probleme mit Verwachsenen im Bauch,
dass sie einen Darmverschluss hatte.
Und da ist sie operiert worden, das hat man aber frühzeitig gemerkt
und das ist, also konnte man so wieder operativ in Ordnung bringen.
Okay.
Wie hat sie, wie hat sie Ihre Mutter?
Ja, die ist Anfang 80.
Anfang 80.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe zwei ältere Brüder, aber also so viel ich weiß, sind die gesund.
Ja, die sind gesund, okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, ich arbeite als Florist.
Florist, gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder, aber die sind natürlich schon groß
und sind schon aus dem Haus.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind zum Glück gesund, ja, ja.
Ja, ich bin gut.
Bohnen Sie mit Ihrer Frau zusammen?
Ja, wir wohnen zusammen, klar.
Ich würde gerne noch mal fragen,
nehmen Sie auch sehr Schmerzmittel, ein Medikament ein?
Ja, wie gesagt, dieses komische Gel dann nämlich für meine Haut im Sommer
und dann, ich weiß gar nicht wofür das ist, das Zylorik, das nehme ich noch ein.
Vielleicht ist das gegen die Gicht, könnte das sein?
Zylorik, ja, kann sein.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Morgen.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Zylorik und Gel.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt, haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, eigentlich nicht, eigentlich möchte ich nur Luft kriegen, ja.
Ja, ich gebe Ihnen jetzt ein Sauerstoff,
aber erst mal muss ich Ihre Bitalparameter kontrollieren,
dann gebe ich Ihnen ein Sauerstoff.
Okay.
Okay, ja, waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Außer?
Nein, war ich nicht.
Haben Sie früher ein Hebich warten?
Nein, so einen Husten hatte ich noch nie.
Aber vielleicht noch eine aktuelle Frage, die man hätte stellen sollen.
Fällt mir aber auch gerade erst ein,
dass man vielleicht nach Corona hätte fragen müssen.
Ja, und Impfungen, Impfstatus, ne?
Wir haben das echt schon so ein bisschen verdrängt,
wir denken da nicht mehr so viel dran.
Das ist verrückt, obwohl es ja immer noch grassiert,
es gibt immer noch Leute, die Corona kriegen, also die Covid-19 kriegen.
Aber wir haben es irgendwie aus unserer Bewusstsein so ziemlich weggeschoben.
Eine Frage hat sonst ähnliche Beschwerden,
hat jetzt bei mir niemand in der Umgebung.
Schönen guten Abend, Frau Obererstin.
Ich habe heute einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie seid haben, ich möchte Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich, wen haben Sie gesehen?
Herr Rudolf Reul, 7.
Wie hätte er?
Rudolf Reul.
Paul.
Und 47 jährige Patienten.
Patient?
Patient, er ist 1,82 Meter groß und 89 kg schwer.
Der Patient stellte sich vor,
weil sie seit 5 Tagen produktiver Husten habe
und aufbegleitet,
habe er 4 mal 39 Grad gemessen.
Er hatte auch ein Dispne beim Husten und Durchatmen.
Und gestern Abend hatte er auch einmal Nachtschweiß.
In der Nacht.
Ja, in der Nacht.
Er hatte auch ein Todrasschmerzen beim Tiefatmen.
Die Schmerzen wurden durchdruckend und brennend beschrieben.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 6 bis 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Die Palpitationen wurden verneint.
Er hatte auch häufige Metrorismus.
Er hat kein Gericht verloren.
Er hatte auch Müdigkeit.
Er ist müde und schlappt.
Er ist seitdem von der chronischen Lumbargie.
Er hat seit 5 Jahren ein Podogra begonnen.
Er hat auch eine solide Schmerzstabilität im Temporalbereich.
Er benutzt manchmal Schmerzstabilität bei Bedarf.
Er hat eine Schmerzstabilität bei Bedarf.
Er hat eine solide Schmerzstabilität bei Bedarf.
Er hat ein linken Dahmenverletzung.
Er hat eine Amoxysilalergie durch exantisch durchgekostet.
Er braucht 10 Zigaretten pro Tag seit 35 Jahren.
Er trinkt abends ein Glas Bier.
Er wurde verneint.
Der Vater des Patients hatte Pynomokoniosi.
Er ist ungefähr mit 80 Jahren verschlafen.
Die Mutter der Patienten hatte Ilios.
Deswegen wurde sie operiert.
Er hat zwei ältere Brüder.
Er ist Florist und verheiratet.
Er hat drei Kinder, die erwachsen sind.
Sie wohnen mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Was ist Ihre Vermutung?
Die Anamnestischen Angaben beachten am ersten auf eine Pynomonie.
Was könnte es alternativ noch sein?
Ich sehe eine COPD.
Und ja, Transilitis oder Erkältung?
Ja, Kultusbranchitis.
Haben Sie nach Covid-Impfung gefragt?
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ich muss fragen.
Covid-Infekt können wir nicht ausschließen.
Ich muss einen Test machen.
Bei der Untersuchung frage ich die Patienten.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ich muss erst einmal die Vitale-Parameter kontrollieren.
Vielleicht Sauerstoff, Sättigung, Pfeffer.
Bei der Ausgiltation muss ich Rasselgeräusche und Kreptation hören.
Bei der Perkussion auf Schalbdämpfung.
Bei der Palpassion stimmt Fremitus.
Oder verschreckte Bronkophonie auch hören.
Bei der Labo-Untersuchung, kleines Blutbilds,
Instruktionsparameter, Nieren und Leberwerte, Elektrolyte.
Ich muss sie kontrollieren.
Sollten Sie Laborte noch untersuchen?
Sputum analysieren.
Was ist die weitere Untersuchung der Wahl?
Ich muss auch Röntgen dranlassen.
Was erwarten Sie zu sehen?
Infiltrationen.
Ja, wenn sich Ihre Vermutung bestätigt,
dass eine Pneumonie hat, was machen wir denn mit dem?
Erstmal würde ich die Partiente stationär behandeln.
Ausstattionär aufnehmen?
Ja, natürlich.
Natürlich gibt es auch eine pflüssigste Antibiotik.
Wie geben Sie die Flüssigkeit?
Ich gebe den Partiente...
Ich gebe die Flüssigkeit.
Der braucht Infusionen.
Antibiotik, worauf achten Sie da?
Er hat eine Amoxicillinallergie.
Deswegen möchte ich andere Pleritormiszenen
oder Kinoline geben.
Was können Sie noch machen, damit es besser geht?
Antibiotik, er hat ein Fieber,
Paracetamol oder Ibuprofen.
Und auch Sauerstoff.
Sauerstoff.
Und Schleimbürger.
Ja, genau.
Dann schauen Sie nach dem Herr Pol
und halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Wir nehmen den stationär auf.
Aber interstichtmedizinisch ist er nicht.
Normalerweise nicht auf die Interstitiation.
Sie haben sich gut durchgekommt.
Eigentlich war es auch kein schwieriger Fall.
Der Patient hatte eine eindeutige Symptomatik.
Im Gegensatz zum letzten Mal ist mir heute aufgefallen,
dass Sie doch so ein bisschen
verharzt sind bei diesem haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie.
Das ist mir jetzt mehr aufgefallen.
Beim letzten Mal hatte ich der Eindruck, Sie bemühen sich gezielt
um andere Formulierungen.
Denken Sie noch mal drüber nach, was man alternativ sagen könnte.
Ein paar Versuche gab es,
was mir dann im Bericht aufgefallen ist,
dass Sie da, wie soll man sagen,
sehr stereotypelsetzige Bildung haben.
Er habe, er habe, er habe, ja.
Man hat sich aller look zu der Fragestellung haben Sie.
Der Patient sagt, er habe, Herr Pol,
kann man auch mal zwischendurch den Namen sagen,
Herr Pol gibt an, dass er,
für nie ein ganz gelauererおいster,
ein bisschen schlagen haben gegenüber
der Oberärztin,
dass er eben auch einen sehr produktiven Husten hat,
mit eilträgerem Auswurf.
Ja, und ich bin mir nicht mehr so sicher.
Also, Nasenbluten haben Sie glaube ich auch nicht
haben sie glaube ich auch nicht erwähnt und so diese insgesamt eingeschränkte Situation,
das System eindeutig schlecht geht. Was mir gut gefallen hat, die Vorerkrankungen haben sie schön
erwähnt. Sie sind ein bisschen zackig von einer Rubrik in die andere rüber gegangen.
Bei der aktuellen Symptomatik haben sie alles komplett beschrieben. An Vorerkrankungen gibt
er, er hat eine Amoxizinealergie, er raucht so und so viel. Die Frage nach Allergien wurde so und so
beantwortet, dass der Patient so viel Zigaretten raucht. Da kann man auch noch mal einen kleinen
überleitenden Satz machen, damit es nicht ganz so schematisch wirkt. Aber das sind eher so
Schönheitsfragen, das ist jetzt nicht grundlegend falsch oder so. Es ist nun nicht so gefällig,
sage ich mal. Sie wollen ja Gefallen, sie wollen ihren Prüfer ein bisschen hohen nicht um den Bart
schmieren. Also tun sie das. Was man überlegen könnte, das müssten vielleicht mal die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen einschätzen und ihre Meinung dazu sagen, ob man bei so einem Patienten erst unterbricht und
erst mal Vitalparameter prüft oder ob man sagt, lasst ihn mal erst erzählen und weiter husten.
Ich meine, das haben wir gemerkt, ich kann nicht 15 Minuten durch husten, das schaffe ich nicht,
wenn ich nicht wirklich husten muss. Aber bei so einem echten Patienten wäre das wahrscheinlich schon so,
dass man sagen würde, Puh, ich gucke jetzt erst mal, was hat der für einen Blutdruck, was hat der für
eine Herzfrequenz und wie ist die Sauerstoffsättigung. Hätte ich jetzt gerne mal so ein Statement von
den Kollegen. Was würden sie sagen, unterbrechen die Befragung und sagen, wir checken die
Vitalparameter oder nicht? Haben wir keinen Prümonologen an Bord? Ja, ich denke, ich musste kontrollieren.
Ich glaube, es wäre zur Sichtgeheite. Ein EK auch schreiben. Ja, dann übrigt sich auch diese Frage
nach dem Herzstolpern oder so. Ein Kollege hat sich geaut und hat gesagt, er würde unterbrechen.
Das wäre eigentlich das Einzige, was ich so ein bisschen kritisch sehe. Und ja, überwiegend haben wir uns ganz gut verstanden.
Was mir noch so ein bisschen aufgefallen ist, eigentlich auch mehr als beim letzten Mal,
weil ich das so richtig erinnere, dass sie ja, dieses, dieses typische eigentlich,
was nicht Muttersprachler halt machen, dass sie eben die Silben so betonen. Ich kann das gar nicht
immer so gut nachmachen. Er hat eine schnelle Atmung oder, oder, oder, ja, er beschreibt,
ja, wo wir eigentlich mit der Stimme schon so runtergehen und und sagen,
ja, er hat produktiven Husten und Atemnot und Atemnot, dass sie dann so jede Silbe so betonen.
Aber so, dass so ein bisschen diese Satzmelodie ein klein bisschen fehlt, aber die Wartmelodie
ein bisschen fehlt. Aber ich denke mal, es tut der Verständlichkeit jetzt keinen Abbruch.
Es ist nur halt so, dass man merkt, da ist kein Muttersprachler, ja, sondern man hört es schon,
dass sie jemand sind, der die Sprache lernen muss. Ja, okay, ich denke mal so viel kann ich für heute
sagen. Aber also, wenn sie nicht vor einem Team total kritischer und schlecht gelaunter Prüfer sitzen,
müsste das eigentlich gut gehen, würde ich sagen. Das wäre meine Erwartung. Ja, gut.